le quartier du chaudron se prépare à la
fête
drapeau affiche le gymnase fonds a
nouvellement est au centre de toutes les
attentions
une fiat et oui il n'ya pas une certaine
fierté de sa maman s'est vu confier par
combien vous gagnez cette fête soit la
prometteuse et complique
pendant que certains cols les premiers
joueurs internationaux arrivées dont
lille trépigne d'impatience alors lui il
a ce petit bonhomme là il vient
d'arriver il ya quelques jours et il
faut savoir qu'il ya dix jours il a été
champion du monde espoirs avec l'équipe
de france à biarritz ils ont battu le
mexique
en finale il ya le défi sportif parce
que comme l'a dit peyo ça va être le
plateau un des plus gros pinceau mondial
avec les meilleures équipes qu'on puis
qu'on peut rencontrer donc ça fait rêver
tout ou plus tard et aujourd'hui on
s'est enlevé un peu se frotter aux
aurores comme commandité aussi on n'a
rien à perdre il faut s'attendre tout
simplement je crois un des meilleurs
tournois si c'est pas le meilleur
mondial qui ait jamais eu dans cette
spécialité la paleta cuir
donc il faut savoir quelle équipe
professionnelle qui va venir cette année
les champions du monde en titre
professionnels composée de l'argentin
pablo fausto et du français sylvain
brefel donc là c'est une équipe très
très solide c'est quasiment ce qui se
fait de mieux actuellement depuis
plusieurs années et après on aura
d'autres espagnols champions du monde
amateur et on aura voilà les petits
français qui arrivent derrière les
réunionnais qui sont voilà qu on me
décrit plus sur la scène internationale
sept jours de compétition 37 sportifs de
haut niveau espagnols argentins et
français
le beau mur à gauche chaudronnés devient
le temps du master international de
pelote le centre du monde
c'est un sport qui est un petit peu
méconnu après lyon donc noir profite que
nous jouer devant notre public pour
pouvoir
faire une animation dans le quartier du
chaudron quoi mais voilà peu rare que le
chaudron il bouffe donc du coup nous là
à nier le sport a demandé sa main
l'utile à l'agréable sur une bonne
moitié comme à la maison en continu ntv
on s'est amusé en initiation marmagne
ouvert à tous
soirée de concerts matinée sport santé
du 12 au 19 novembre
la pelote enfin la réunion ce que le
sport a de meilleur